sur la route vers Camp-Perrin une partie
de la montagne c'est littéralement des
versets sur le chemin principal
des maisons effondrées longe la route
témoignant de la violence du tremblement
de terre il y a 4 jours à peine
cette grand-mère nous raconte que ses 3
petits-enfants se trouvait dans cette
pièce lors du séisme qui se font soigner
à Port-au-Prince et au caille c'est elle
qui les élèves
oui mais là où il mal de samedi quand il
a tombé sur lui mais
pas de victimes
semble avoir sauvé sa famille car ces
maisons semblent avoir mieux résisté que
celle en béton
sur
maison
ici à Mazenod de lieux spirituels où les
prés troubles Haïtiens sont la retraite
deux personnes sont mortes sous les
décombres
le collège Le Petit Séminaire le prénom
maison toute notre
être sauvé
bon après le temps de la maison c'était
cousin
dans le retour
tu es
[Musique]
encore en vie
elle attend son 8e enfant avec
impatience car malgré tout la vie doit
continuer il y a des beaux dégâts
Radio-Canada Capeyron Haïti